we average one sexual thought every 7
seconds but sexual energy can be
diverted
you're a superstar new Tony Robinson he
suppresses people's natural desires
strike up the band you're kind you're
funny you're pretty damn amazing about
peace he's not gay call you tomorrow
you're lucky that you date dudes no I'm
not actually dead serious about that if
you ladies are ready its little
basketball oh really
could shut the nut smell some things
melon they're like well quail eggs
we found a brain tumor I begin to your
pituitary gland pressure it's applied
has watched a normal male development
basically you've never gone through
puberty got the penis of Stephen Hawking
at the moment I don't want to split
hairs but Stephen Hawking could actually
get an erection
so it's Cupid II at 30 going you got
home I'm horny I'm Moody and acting a
little nuts to the puberty is happening
at an accelerated speed pardon the
interruption but do you drive a silver
branded session my office now we have 25
minutes
hey hey Franco would you mind if I pop
those on youtube I have to take a rain
check people put their lives aside in
pursuit of their next organism orgasm I
don't know you just seem different
Keith you've been avoiding me oh just
realize I'm late and I gotta go
you'll never get it you can act out baby
we're waiting 15 years for him to do
that
you
you